In the early 2000s, Alibaba launched Alipay to facilitate user transactions on Taobao,...
...the Chinese equivalent of eBay.
Around the end of the decade, Taobao introduced its mobile wallet features...
...to let Alipay members transfer money to one another...
...or split bills using QR codes.
Good timing.
That was right when the number of mobile users in China began to skyrocket.
One of the biggest reasons is the fact that smartphones in China are really cheap.
And that's made the smartphone really affordable for the masses.
And many people began finding themselves in China's supercharged economy...
...with more money in their bank accounts...
...and began linking those accounts to Alipay.
Not many Chinese people had credit cards.
One factor, Chinese authorities made it difficult for Visa and Mastercard...
...to get a foothold there.
In 2013, Alipay passed PayPal as the world's largest mobile payment platform.
That same year, Tencent got in on the action,...
...bringing mobile payments to its widely popular WeChat app.
In just three years,...
...the newcomer has grabbed up 40% of China's mobile payment transactions.
This was the year before Apple announced Apple Pay...
...which in terms of users, is now way behind its Chinese rivals.